steve can you explain the structure of a
romantic comedy and how does that differ
from the structure of a dark comedy
uh i you know i think uh
the structures are actually not that
dissimilar um
uh in a romantic comedy you have
a protagonist um who
is uh has taken an
awkward stance in life um just think of
uh the image of a man slipping on a
banana peel that's
you see somebody kind of waving their
arms away looking for balance and
in a in a comedy the the comic paradigm
the
the comic hero's journey is that you
have you start your film
with this character being off balance
but not knowing it
bill murray thinks all he needs is to
work at a bigger network and really he's
he's a
misanthropic miserable guy
um sandra bullock in um
and while you were sleeping is
desperately
uh you know locked in to herself
but she thinks well that's the way it's
always going to be um
in when harry met sally uh billy crystal
thinks he knows everything there is to
know about women he's got it all figured
out he's got
all the answers uh and and what happens
is
is something occurs the catalyst
uh the premise something occurs that
pushes this character off balance and
what they do is they spend the first
part of the film
desperately trying to return to the
normal world
which they're used to but which we in
the audience see is desperately off
balance is the wrong
stance in the world for them and along
the way
as they're trying as they're going on
this journey to re
to return to where they started from
they start to
realize they they become aware they
discover
that there's a whole new way to learn
way to
where there's a whole new way to stand
in the world
and and to make them a a whole person
so in both romantic comedy and in in
regular comings and dark comedies
you have characters who are desperately
uh struggling to
retain the kind of contorted
stance they have in the world and they
learn to
stand straight in the world and they so
every character in a comedy every
protagonist
has to start with a hole in them some
something lacking something missing
because that's what the journey's about
to to to
become a better human being in a dark
comedy uh
the writer is not so much interested in
the person becoming a better human being
as much as uh kind of revealing how
really miserable the world is and maybe
the character
finds out in in really dark comedies
the characters lose like in um wag the
dog
but even in in most satirical comedies
you do want the character to have some
kind of
moment of of satisfaction
you know what some people might think of
a happy ending but
but really you don't want the character
to end up
beaten and miserable that's three
quarters of the way through the movie
you want the character to have learned
something
and become a better person because of it
um julia roberts in my best friend's
wedding
it would be horrible if she ended up
ruining uh cameron diaz's wedding and
still being unhappy of herself and
you know and then going off by yourself
it's it's impossible you could do that
but i think as an audience we're all
more satisfied
with her not getting the guy
but learning a lesson that she's
satisfied with she's
satisfied that she doesn't get the guy
because she's gotten something else
she's gotten
a better understanding of who she is and
how to live in the world
you